يعني هنا استهداف اسرائيلي امام مجمع
الشفاء الطبي هناك عدد من المصابين
والشهداء هذا المجمع يعني بين الفينه
والاخرى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تقتل الاهالي بداخلها هؤلاء
كما تشاهدون استهدفتهم قذيفه اسرائيليه
والان هم محاصرين لا يستطيع الاهالي
انتشالهم لوجود قناصه اسرائيليه هذا هذا
مصاب هذا مصاب يحاول باي طريقه من الطرق
ان ان يخرج
من مرمى نيران القناصه الاسرائيليه بجواره
شهيد اشلاء هذا المشهد الذي امامكم يظهر
مشهد بالغ الصعوبه هناك اربع شهداء امام
مجمع الشفاء الطبي الطواقم الطبيه تخشى
القناصه
الاسرائيليه الله اكبر على
اليهود
ا
معلم الله يحميك الله يحميك الله ير العج
شباب هذه كما تشاهدون هذا رغم وجود تعال
[موسيقى]
هنا هذه بطرت يده كما تشاهدون يده مبتوره
وهذا شهيد ويقال ان يوجد شهيدين اخرين في
هذه اللحظات قذيفه اسرائيليه استهدفتهم في
مجمع الشفاء امام مجمع الشفاء
الطبي الري
افتري ط
مقطعه اذا نحن
نتحدث اها هذا شهيد اشلاء هذا قسمت
القذيفه هؤلاء الى
اشلا
الله شهداء واصا